[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
niedrigen schönen guten abend an diesem
freitag der aus politischer sicht ein
ziemlich spannende an aufschlussreicher
ist alles sportliche in dieser sendung
wieder mit kristin otto wolle vor der
guten abend dann blicken wir jetzt
gemeinsam auf einige der wichtigsten
themen von heute
erfolgreiche ampel sondierungen spd
grüne und fdp wollen
koalitionsverhandlungen einleiten und
präsentieren erste kompromisse
3g pflicht am arbeitsplatz beschäftigt
den italien müssen ab sofort nachweisen
dass sie geimpft genesen oder negativ
getestet sind es kommt zu heftigen
protesten und
[Musik]
ökostrom umlage sinkt deutlich offen
bleibt wie viel bei den verbrauchern
davon tatsächlich ankommt
ja es ist die polit nachricht des tages
die ampel parteien sind sich einig haben
das ausgesprochen womit viele schon
rechneten sie empfehlen
koalitionsverhandlungen dazu ein
vergleichsweise begeisterter spd
kanzlerkandidat
insgesamt kann man sehr spüren hier ist
ein aufbruch möglich getragen von den
dreien parteien die hier zusammenkommen
für mich persönlich dass wir dich gerne
noch sagen ist es sehr bemerkenswert wie
vertrauensvoll und konstruktiv die
gespräche über auch unterschiedliche
ausgangspositionen stattfinden soweit
also olaf scholz und auch alle anderen
beteiligten äußern sich demonstrativ
erfreut vertraulichkeit konstruktive
zusammenarbeit das betonen alle und auf
dem tisch liegt nun ein durchaus schon
detailreicher zwölf seiten kompromiss
christoph festival mit den wichtigsten
punkten
arbeit und soziales der mindestlohn soll
auf zwölf euro pro stunde steigen statt
hartz 4 ist ein bürgergeld geplant um so
möglichst unbürokratisch alle
sozialleistungen zu bündeln bei der
rente soll es bleiben wie es ist keine
kürzung der bezüge und keine anhebung
des renteneintrittsalters
klima und verkehr der ausstieg aus der
kohle wird laut plan vorgezogen wenn
möglich schon auf 2.030 dagegen ist das
tempolimit auf autobahnen vom tisch
finanzen die schuldenbremse soll weiter
gelten und auch steuererhöhungen sind
nicht vorgesehen damit sich das ganze
trotzdem rechnet kommen alle derzeitigen
subventionen auf dem prüfstand
gleichzeitig sollen investitionen
gefördert werden vor allem die in den
klimaschutz nebenbei würde das so der
plan die konjunktur anschieben und geld
in die kassen spülen geld dass es
dringend braucht vor allem für das eine
große projekt der ampel parteien die
modernisierung und digitalisierung der
gesamten gesellschaft
über die bilanz der ampel parteien
sprechen wir gleich mit unserer
hauptstadt korrespondentin lassen uns
zuvor aber noch den rot grün gelben
auftritt von patricia wiedemeier
einordnen heute morgen vor der tür
erneute demonstrationen für mehr
klimaschutz und es scheint dass sie
erhört wurden die ganze nacht war
verhandelt worden gegen mittag dann
präsentierten spd grüne und fdp 1 12
seitiges sondierungs papier das große
ziel die industrielle aber vor allem
auch ökologische modernisierung des
landes
das bedeutet dass wir einen massiven
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
brauchen damit es möglich ist dass wir
so schnell wie möglich auf die nutzung
fossiler ressourcen verzichten können es
wird das größte industrielle
modernisierungsprojekt dass deutschland
wahrscheinlich seit über 100 jahren
durchgeführt hat es war ein geben und
nehmen die spd setzt den mindestlohn von
12 euro durch die fdp verhindert
steuererhöhungen und tempolimit die
grünen bekommen mehr klimaschutz
damit wir nicht nur auf den kleinsten
gemeinsamen nenner weiter politik in
diesem land machen sondern in einer
fortschritts koalition auch für eine
wirkliche erneuerung sorgen war es
wichtig dass bei drei unterschiedlichen
parteien ein verständnis da ist dass
jeder auch mal was gibt
übereinstimmend loben alle den guten
umgang miteinander den vertraulichen ton
selten zuvor gab es so euphorische
statements wir sind überzeugt nach
diesen gesprächen
dass
es lange zeit
keine vergleichbare chance gegeben hat
gesellschaft wirtschaft und staat zu
modernisieren
der große gewinner einer solchen
koalition wird am ende nicht eine
einzelne partei sein sondern unser land
doch wie diese modernisierung finanziert
werden soll das blieb heute weitgehend
offen eines der themen für die kommenden
koalitionsverhandlungen
der spd vorstand hat heute bereits der
aufnahme der gespräche zugestimmt
den auftritt heute und das
sondierungsteam hat chuck und sarah
banerjee in berlin sich ganz genau
angeschaut haben wir hier schon die
nächste bundesregierung und ihren
kanzler gesehen dass die drei
verhandlungspartner sind diesem ziel
zumindest heute einen guten schritt
näher gekommen denn dieses sondierungs
papier beschreibt immerhin einige ideen
wie man die teils tiefen gräben zwischen
diesen drei sehr unterschiedlichen
parteien überbrücken könnte und ganz
wichtig das papier hält es eben
schriftlich fest da steht jetzt für alle
drei beteiligten schwarz auf weiß darauf
hinter welche zusagen man nicht mehr
zurückfallen möchte und das schafft
natürlich sicherheit für die nächsten
verhandlungstag stellung durch diverse
kompromisse was könnte denn jetzt noch
schief gehen ja da gibt es tatsächlich
noch einige fallstricke denn die ideen
die der beschrieben werden die müssen ja
jetzt noch mit leben gefüllt werden und
vor allem muss einmal ausbuchstabiert
werden wie das ganze finanziert werden
soll da ist die frage offen wie ihr die
drei potenziellen koalitionäre mehr geld
ausgeben wollen ohne auch mehr schulden
zu machen das haben sie sich ja
gegenseitig versprochen das haben sie
bisher ausgespart und auch die frage des
personals ist bisher noch nicht
angesprochen worden da geht es aber dann
eben ans eingemachte posten sind macht
und diesen posten poker hat man sich
aufgehoben auch da gibt es noch einigen
konfliktstoff abwarten es bleibt also
spannend danke jacke und heller nach
berlin
spd grüne und fdp sind jedenfalls fest
entschlossen eine regierung zu bilden
deckt sich auch mit den wünschen der
bürgerinnen und bürger sagt das
brandneue zdf politbarometer das und
weitere markante zahlen zum beispiel
auch zur union hat pablo sila
die koalitionsgespräche haben noch nicht
einmal begonnen doch olaf scholz bekommt
schon jetzt großen zuspruch aus der
bevölkerung laut zdf-politbarometer
fänden es 75 prozent der deutschen eher
gut wenn der sozialdemokrat tatsächlich
bundeskanzler werden würde nur 17
prozent eher schlecht
sogar die mehrheit der unions-anhänger
fände olaf scholz gut als kanzler ein
von ihm geführtes ampel bündnis mit
grünen und fdp wünschen sich 62 prozent
bittere zahlen hingegen für die union
während sich die spd in der
sonntagsfrage stabil bei 28 prozent hält
verlieren cdu csu einen prozentpunkt und
landen bei 19 prozent unter
20 prozent so schwach war die union noch
nie im politbarometer und fast zwei
drittel der befragten gehen davon aus
dass die schwäche von cdu/csu länger
anhalten wird dass der union jetzt
konservativere positionen helfen würden
glaubt nur etwa jeder vierte die
diskussion über ihre künftigen
positionen darauf deutet derzeit alles
hin wird die union wohl in der
opposition führen müssen
und ausführlich können sie das
zdf-politbarometer ab 22 uhr im heute
journal sehen oder schon jetzt online in
unserer zdf heute app dort finden sie
alle zahlen und grafiken auch zum
durchklicken
jetzt zum thema corona die jüngsten sind
mehrheitlich weniger betroffen von
schweren verläufen und sie sind es die
sich gerade vor allem anstecken und das
laut robert-koch-institut regional sehr
unterschiedlich in acht kreisen sowie in
rosenheim liegt die inzidenz bei den
zehn- bis 19-jährigen sogar bei mehr als
500 insgesamt sieht es bei den zahlen so
aus 11.500 18 neuinfektionen binnen
eines tages meldet das rk ii
1089 mehr als vor einer woche 65
todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben tage
instituts steigt leicht auf jetzt
68,7
wir bleiben beim thema corona blicken
nach italien ein großteil der
bevölkerung ist dort schon geimpft und
trotzdem erhöht die regierung weiter den
druck auf ungeimpfte seit heute gilt
eine corona pass pflicht am arbeitsplatz
damit muss jeder arbeitnehmer entweder
geimpft gewesen oder negativ getestet
sein ansonsten drohen heftige strafen
etwa ein bußgeld bis zu 1500 euro aus
rom annette hilsenbeck
im yachthafen von rom muss chef
alessandro may seit heute kontrollieren
ob seine 25 mitarbeiter den sogenannten
green pass haben der digitale ausweis
der belegt dass man entweder geimpft von
corona genesen oder aktuellen negativ
getestet ist
das ist ein unkompliziertes systems
garantiert allen arbeitern ein bisschen
mehr sicherheit mehr grüne pass verrät
dem arbeitgeber nicht ob die person
geimpftes oder frisch getestet wer
allerdings keinen vorweist wird von der
arbeit freigestellt und zwar ohne
bezahlung italiens regierung will so
bisher ungeimpfte motivieren
es werden gerade viele erst impfungen
durchgeführt die menschen lassen sich
weiterhin impfen wir sind jetzt bei mehr
als 80 prozent der bevölkerung über
zwölf jahre die vollständig geimpft sind
gegen den green pass auch heute wieder
heftige proteste im hafen von triest von
jenen die das gesetz als diskriminierend
bezeichnet
und in ancona an der adria streikten
lastwagenfahrer der transportbereich
ohnehin unter spannung nun auch noch der
widerstand gegen den greenpeace die
große mehrheit aber ist in italien
geimpft und die regierung will
weitermachen um die korona krise hinter
sich zu lassen
schock in großbritannien ein
abgeordneter der regierenden
konservativen ist bei einem messer
angriff getötet worden das attentat
geschah in einer kirche östlich von
london dort hatte sich der 69 jährige
david james mit bürgern seines
wahlkreises getroffen medienberichten
zufolge starb der angreifer mehrfach auf
ihn ein die polizei nahm einen 25
jährigen mann fest die hintergründe sind
noch unklar
in afghanistan hat es erneut einen
anschlag auf eine schiitische moschee
gegeben mehr als 30 menschen wurden bei
dem selbstmordattentat in der provinz
kandahar getötet
augenzeugen berichten von mehreren
explosionen während des freitagsgebetes
erst vor einer woche hatte es einen
ähnlichen anschlag in kundus gegeben zu
dem sich die terror miliz es bekannte
verzweifelte menschen zum beispiel aus
irak oder syrien die von einem besseren
leben in europa träumt versuchen die
flucht mit hilfe von schleusern und die
also die schleuse haben seit dem sommer
eine neue route entdeckt über belarus
dort reisen die flüchtlinge völlig legal
ein und dann schlagen sie sich illegal
über die grenze vor allem nach polen
durch und von dort weiter nach
deutschland
4300 waren es seit august aus
brandenburg berichtet anja klingbeil
der 31 jährige mohammad erzählt uns wie
er aus syrien nach deutschland kam
zunächst mit dem flugzeug nach minsk
dann weiter zu fuß durch die wälder von
belarus und polen 16 stunden ohne pause
ich bin wirklich sehr glücklich hier zu
sein und ich wünsche mir dass es hier
gut geht
seit august reisen immer mehr menschen
über belarus und polen unerlaubt nach
deutschland ein im moment täglich 100
bis 150 inzwischen kommen auch familien
doch überwiegend sind es allein reisende
mohammad geht es darum hier beruflich
fuß zu fassen
ich möchte hier bleiben und studieren
dann will ich arbeiten und gut für
deutschland sein
sie kommen aus syrien dem irak
afghanistan und iran nach der
registrierung hier in der erstaufnahme
eisenhüttenstadt finden sie auch in
zelten eine vorläufige bleibe
der belarussische präsident alexander
lukaschenko hatte es angekündigt er
wolle niemanden aufhalten der weiter
richtung westen reise eine reaktion auf
die sanktionen der eu brandenburgs
innenminister fordert nun eine
außenpolitische lösung wichtig ist dass
ich hier sowohl die eu kommission aber
auch das bundesaußenministerium
verstärkt einsetzt denn wir haben es
hier mit menschenhandel der übelsten
form zu tun
unterstützung vom bund wurde bereits
zugesagt spätestens in zwei wochen
sollen die geflüchteten direkt in alle
bundesländer weitergeleitet werden so
wie es der verteilschlüssel vorgibt
gute nachrichten für die fast 900.000
beschäftigten in der baubranche
arbeitgeber und gewerkschaft haben sich
in der vergangenen nacht auf ein
tarifpaket geeinigt streiks sind damit
vom tisch so steigen die löhne in 33
monaten laufzeit im osten um insgesamt
8,5 prozent im westen um 6,2 damit
gleichen die sich weiter an dazu kommen
einmalzahlung und eine entschädigung für
die oft langen anfahrtszeiten zur
baustelle
wer eine marode immobilie besitzt und
diese sanieren will der bekommt
rückenwind vom bundesgerichtshof geklagt
hatte das mitglied einer
eigentümergemeinschaft dabei ging es um
die sanierung einzelner etagen eines
parkhauses die die anderen eigentümer
ablehnten der bgh urteilte nun ein
gebäude dürfe nicht einfach verfallen
dies sei rechtswidrig verfallene häuser
müssten auch instand gesetzt werden wenn
die sanierungskosten den aktuellen wert
übersteigen
alle die sich über aktuell
explodierender energiepreise ärgern
dürften jetzt aufhorchen die eeg-umlage
also die umlage die die stromkunden zum
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien zahlen
sinkt und zwar deutlich statt wie bisher
6,5 cent pro kilowattstunde werden im
kommenden jahr nur noch 3,7 zwei cent
fällig so wenig wie seit zehn jahren
nicht mehr warum sich verbraucher wohl
trotzdem nicht auf eine niedrigere
stromrechnungen einstellen können dazu
jetzt ralph goldmann
der ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
kostet geld private stromkunden zahlen
dafür den preis knapp 32 cent kostet
derzeit eine kilowattstunde die umlage
beträgt ab januar 3,7 cent sie fällt
auch deshalb so gering aus weil der bund
3,25 milliarden zuschießt
ist eine gute nachricht für
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher für die
wirtschaft für den mittelstand und ich
erwarte von den
stromversorgungsunternehmen dass sie
diese preissenkung auch an die kunden an
die endkunden weitergeben allerdings
erhöhen derzeit viele versorger sogar
ihre tarife teils drastisch so könnte es
für die verbraucher am ende ein
nullsummenspiel werden fürchten experten
die eeg umlage ist eine komponente vom
strompreis wir haben aber auch noch den
netzentgelt und die beschaffung der
energieversorger und beides tendiert
nach oben also wird im kommenden jahr
teurer
deswegen gehen wir davon aus dass die
eeg umlage nicht zu einer senkung der
strompreise führen wird dabei zahlen die
deutschen schon jetzt weltweit die
höchsten strompreise wegen hoher steuern
und andere abgaben bemängelt oliver
krischer von den grünen
wir haben viel zu hohe
grundversorgungstarife in deutschland wo
gesetzliche regelung gerade für arme
menschen besonders schlecht sind da gibt
es einfach ein riesen handlungsfeld und
das muss in zukunft einfach anders
werden die politik ist sich einig
irgendwann soll die umlage ganz
wegfallen die frage ist nur wann offen
ist auch wie der wegfall dann finanziert
werden soll
das steht seit mehr als 30 jahren auch
für einen linksautonomen projekt im
berliner bezirk mitte heute hat die
polizei das bauwagen camp in der
köpenicker straße geräumt der einsatz
dauerte mehrere stunden einige bewohner
kletterten auf bäume banken sich dort
fest 21 menschen wurden vorübergehend
festgenommen darunter auch teilnehmer
von unterstützer demonstrationen der
grundstücksbesitzer hatte die räumung
gerichtlich erstritten für den abend
sind weitere proteste angekündigt
die insel la palma kommt weiter nicht
zur ruhe respekt einflößende lavamassen
sie sehen es aus dem vulkan suchen sich
ihren weg zum meer dabei ist der 1200
grad heiße lava floss noch heftiger und
wesentlich schneller geworden wegen der
näher rückenden gefahr ordneten die
behörden die evakuierung von weiteren
300 menschen an seit ausbruch des
vulkans mussten etwa 7000 ihr zuhause
verlassen
schon ihre bilder es geht jetzt
sportlich weiter mit der christlichen
auf fußball zuerst wird spannend in der
bundesliga achter spieltag mit der
partie der spitzenreiter am sonntag der
tabellenzweite bayer leverkusen empfängt
den ersten bayern münchen beide vereine
punktgleich ein ewig reizvolles duell
mit interessanten vergleichen
florian würz leverkusen und jamal
musealer bayern münchen das spitzenspiel
bietet eine direkte gegenüberstellung
der beiden größten deutschen fußball
talente als musealer nach überstandener
verletzung von beginn an spielt die
immense veranlagung der beiden
18-jährigen hat beigetragen zum sprung
ihrer vereine die tabellenspitze bei
wirz mit vier treffern sicher noch mehr
als bei musealer bayern-coach nagelsmann
plant etwas überraschend mit
abwehrspieler luke ernanntes obwohl der
am nächsten dienstag in madrid vor einem
strafgericht erscheinen muss ganz
normale lebt gar keinen gar keinen
irgendwelche negativen auswirkung
wahrgenommen ob leverkusens neuer
trainer ioan mit seinem team den bayern
paroli bieten kann das wollen 30.000 in
der schon jetzt ausverkauften bayarena
miterleben
die frauen mannschaft der bayern freut
sich über den ersten triumph in der
neuen champions-league-saison zweifache
torschützin binnen zwei minuten in
münchen die überragende
nationalspielerin lehrer schüler
letztlich wurde ein müheloses 4 0 gegen
die schwedischen meisterinnen vom bk
häcken verbucht
und der traum vom endspiel wie 2009 10
in indian wells ist für angelique kerber
geplatzt endstation viertelfinale heißt
es für deutschlands beste
tennisspielerin
sichtlich frustriert ist angelique
kerber nach dem matchball und
ausgepowert die dreimalige grand slam
turnier gewinnerin verliert satz 1 gegen
die spanier in pau labbadia mit 46 vor
allem aber durchgang zwei kostet kraft
nach einem 2 5-rückstand gewinnt die
deutsche drei spiele nacheinander muss
sich aber letztendlich geschlagen geben
das ende dann fast symptomatisch mit
einem fehler zum 57 beendet kerber die
partie sie hat jetzt kaum noch chancen
sich für die wta final zum saisonende zu
qualifizieren
und die sind in drei wochen in mexiko
vielen dank christian mexiko vielleicht
gutes stichwort viel sonne und milde
temperaturen stehen nicht ganz richtig
wie in mexiko aber die kleine ausnahmen
die überlassen wir gleich mal katja
horneffer um 22 uhr empfehlen wir claus
kleber und das heute journal wir
bedanken uns fürs zuschauen war schön
mit ihnen morgen begrüßt sie dann jana
pareigis um 19 uhr schön freitagabend
noch für sie
[Musik]
guten abend das unwetter tief über dem
östlichen mittelmeer hat kräftig
überschwemmungen gebracht in
griechenland zum beispiel auch in athen
es löst sich jetzt am wochenende auf und
auflösen wird sich auch die kaltfront
die uns ja heute im wesentlichen
überquert hat über der mitte
deutschlands da löst sie sich gerade auf
und zu fällt heute nacht kaum noch regen
wenn dann höchstens mal hier am main
sonst ist mal mehr mal weniger stark
bewölkt es bildet sich auch mal nebel
und es wird kalt die temperaturen sinken
meist auf plus fünf bis minus 1 grad es
droht also hier und da auch wieder
bodenfrost deutlich milder bleibt die
nacht an der see bei 10 bis 7 grad und
morgen liegen die höchsttemperaturen
meist um 13 grad und nach nebel und
dunst am morgen scheint dann doch in
süddeutschland häufig die sonne richtung
norddeutschland sind die wolken dichter
und an den küsten von nord- und ostsee
in schleswig-holstein da kann es auch
mal ein bisschen regnen bei westwind am
sonntag ändert sich an diesem wetter
eigentlich wenig aber in der neuen woche
da wird es erst mal milder und dann aber
von westen deutlich regnerischer und
windiger die temperaturen am mittwoch
steigen bis 22 grad schönes wochenende